The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: Finally we get
to positive definite matrices.
I've used the word and now
it's time to pin it down.
And so this would be my
thank you for staying with it
while we do this important
preliminary stuff
about linear algebra.
So starting the
next lecture we'll
really make a big start on
engineering applications.
But these matrices are going
to be the key to everything.
And I'll call these matrices
K. And positive definite,
I will only use that word
about a symmetric matrix.
So the matrix is
already symmetric
and that means it
has real eigenvalues
and many other
important properties,
orthogonal eigenvectors.
And now we're asking for more.
And it's that extra
bit that is terrific
in all kinds of applications.
So if I can do this
bit of linear algebra.
So what's coming then, my review
session this afternoon at four,
I'm very happy that
we've got, I think,
the best MATLAB problem ever
invented, in 18.085 anyway.
So that should get onto the
website probably by tomorrow.
And Peter Buchak is
like the MATLAB person.
So his review sessions
are Friday at noon.
And I just saw him and
suggested Friday at noon
he might as well
just stay in here.
And knowing that
that isn't maybe
a good hour for everybody.
So you could see him also
outside of that hour.
But that's the hour
he will be ready
for all kinds of questions about
MATLAB or about the homeworks.
Actually you'll be probably
thinking more about, also
about the homework
questions on this topic.
Ready for positive definite?
You said yes, right?
And you have a hint
about these things.
So we have a symmetric
matrix and the beauty
is that it brings together
all of linear algebra.
Including elimination,
that's when we see pivots.
Including determinants which are
closely related to the pivots.
And what do I mean
by upper left?
I mean that if I have a three
by three symmetric matrix
and I want to test it
for positive definite,
and I guess actually
this would be the easiest
test if I had a tiny
matrix, three by three,
and I had numbers, then
this would be a good test.
The determinants-- By upper left
determinants I mean that one
by one determinant.
So just that first number
has to be positive.
Then the two by two determinant,
that times that minus that
times that has to be positive.
Oh I've already
been saying that.
Let me just put in some letters.
So a has to be positive.
This is symmetric,
so a times c has
to be bigger than b squared.
So that will tell us.
And then for two
by two we finish.
For three by three we would
also require the three
by three determinant
to be positive.
But already here
you're seeing one point
about a positive
definite matrix.
Its diagonal will
have to be positive.
And somehow its diagonal has
to be not just above zero,
but somehow it has
to defeat b squared.
So the diagonal has to
be somehow more positive
than whatever
negative stuff might
come from off the diagonal.
That's why I would need
a*c &gt; b squared.
So both of those
will be positive
and their product has to be
bigger than the other guy.
And then finally, a third test
is that all the eigenvalues
are positive.
And of course if I give you
a three by three matrix,
that's probably not
the easiest test
since you'd have to
find the eigenvalues.
Much easier to find the
determinants or the pivots.
Actually, just while I'm at it,
so the first pivot of course
is a itself.
No difficulty there.
The second pivot turns out
to be the ratio of a*c -
b squared to a.
So the connection between
pivots and determinants
is just really close.
Pivots are ratios
of determinants,
if you work it out.
The second pivot, maybe
I would call that d_2,
is the ratio of a*c
- b squared over a.
In other words it's
c minus b^2 / a.
Determinants are
positive and vice versa.
Then it's fantastic
that the eigenvalues
come into the picture.
So those are three ways,
three important properties
of a positive definite matrix.
But I'd like to make the
definition something different.
Now I'm coming to the meaning.
If I think of those as
the tests, that's done.
Now the meaning of
positive definite.
The meaning of positive
definite and the applications
are closely related to
looking for a minimum.
And so what I'm going to bring
in here-- So it's symmetric.
Now for a symmetric matrix I
want to introduce the energy.
So this is the reason why
it has so many applications
and such important
physical meaning is
that what I'm
about to introduce,
which is a function
of x, and here
it is, it's x transpose
times A, not A,
I'm sticking with K
for my matrix, times x.
I think of that as some f(x).
And let's just see what it
would be if the matrix was
two by two, [a, b; b, c].
Suppose that's my matrix.
We want to get a handle on
what, this is the first time
I've ever written something
that has x's times x's.
So it's going to be quadratic.
They're going to
be x's times x's.
And x is a general
vector of the right size
so it's got components x_1, x_2.
And there it's
transposed, so it's a row.
And now I put in
the [a, b; b,  c].
And then I put in x again.
This is going to give me a
very nice, simple, important
expression.
Depending on x_1 and x_2.
Now what is, can we do
that multiplication?
Maybe above I'll do the
multiplication of this pair
and then I have the
other guy to bring in.
So here, that
would be ax_1+bx_2.
And this would be bx_1+cx_2.
So that's the first,
that's this times this.
What am I going to get?
What shape, what size is
this result going to be?
This K is n by n. x is a column
vector. n by one. x transpose,
what's the shape of x transpose?
One by n?
So what's the total result?
One by one.
Just a number.
Just a function.
It's a number.
But it depends on the x's
and the matrix inside.
Can we do it now?
So I've got this to
multiply by this.
Do you see an x_1
squared showing up?
Yes, from there times there.
And what's it multiplied by?
The a.
The first term is this times
the ax_1 is a x_1 squared.
So that's our first quadratic.
Now there'd be an x_1, x_2.
Let me leave that for a minute
and find the x_2 squared
because it's easy.
So where am I going
to get x_2 squared?
I'm going to get that
from x_2, second guy
here times second guy here.
There's a c x_2 squared.
So you're seeing already
where the diagonal shows up.
The diagonal a, c,
whatever, is multiplying
the perfect squares.
And it'll be the off-diagonal
that multiplies the x_1 x_2.
We might call those
the cross terms.
And what do we
get for that then?
We have x_1 times this guy.
So that's a cross
term. bx_1*x_2, right?
And here's another one coming
from x_2 times this guy.
And what's that one?
It's also bx_1*x_2.
So x_1, multiply that,
x_2 multiply that,
and so what do we have
for this cross term here?
Two of them.
2bx_1*x_2.
In other words, that b
and that b came together
in the 2bx_1*x_2.
So here's my energy.
Can I just loosely
call it energy?
And then as we get to
applications we'll see why.
So I'm interested
in that because it
has important meaning.
Well, so now I'm ready to define
positive definite matrices.
So I'll call that number four.
But I'm going to
give it a big star.
Even more because
it's the sort of key.
So the test will be, you
can probably guess it,
I look at this expression,
that x transpose Ax.
And if it's a positive
definite matrix
and this represents
energy, the key
will be that this
should be positive.
This one should be
positive for all x's.
Well, with one
exception, of course.
All x's except, which vector
is it? x=0 would just give me--
See, I put K. My default for a
matrix, but should be, it's K.
Except x=0, except
the zero vector.
Of course.
If x_1 and x_2 are both zero.
Now that looks a little
maybe less straightforward,
I would say, because it's
a statement about this
is true for all x_1 and x_2.
And we better do some
examples and draw a picture.
Let me draw a
picture right away.
So here's x_1 direction.
Here's x_2 direction.
And here is the x
transpose Ax, my function.
So this depends
on two variables.
So it's going to be a sort
of a surface if I draw it.
Now, what point do
we absolutely know?
And I put A again.
I am so sorry.
Well, we know one point.
It's there whatever
that matrix might be.
It's there.
Zero, right?
You just told me that if
both x's are zero then
we automatically get zero.
Now what do you think
the shape of this curve,
the shape of this graph
is going to look like?
The point is, if we're
positive definite now.
So I'm drawing the picture
for positive definite.
So my definition is
that the energy goes up.
It's positive, right?
When I leave, when I move away
from that point I go upwards.
That point will be a minimum.
Let me just draw it roughly.
So it sort of goes up like this.
These cheap 2-D boards and I've
got a three-dimensional picture
here.
But you see it somehow?
What word or what's
your visualization?
It has a minimum there.
That's why minimization,
which was like,
the core problem in
calculus, is here now.
But for functions
of two x's or n x's.
We're up the dimension over
the basic minimum problem
of calculus.
It's sort of like a parabola.
Its cross-sections cutting
down through the thing
would be just parabolas
because of the x squared.
I'm going to call this a bowl.
It's a short word.
Do you see it?
It opens up.
That's the key point,
that it opens upward.
And let's do some examples.
Tell me some positive definite.
So positive definite
and then let
me here put some not
positive definite cases.
Tell me a matrix.
Well, what's the
easiest, first matrix
that occurs to you as a
positive definite matrix?
The identity.
That passes all our tests,
its eigenvalues are one,
its pivots are one, the
determinants are one.
And the function is
x_1 squared plus x_2
squared with no b in it.
It's just a perfect bowl,
perfectly symmetric,
the way it would come
off a potter's wheel.
Now let me take one
that's maybe not so,
let me put a nine there.
So I'm off to a
reasonable start.
I have an x_1 squared
and a nine x_2 squared.
And now I want to
ask you, what could I
put in there that would
leave it positive definite?
Well, give me a couple
of possibilities.
What's a nice, not too
big now, that's the thing.
Two.
Two would be fine.
So if I had a two there and
a two there I would have
a 4x_1*x_2 and it
would, like, this,
instead of being a circle,
which it was for the identity,
the plane there would cut
out a ellipse instead.
But it would be a good ellipse.
Because we're doing
squares, we're really,
the Greeks understood
these second degree things
and they would have known this
would have been an ellipse.
How high can I go with that
two or where do I have to stop?
Where would I have to, if
I wanted to change the two,
let me just focus on that one,
suppose I wanted to change it.
First of all, give
me one that's,
how about the borderline.
Three would be the borderline.
Why's that?
Because at three we have nine
minus nine for the determinant.
So the determinant is zero.
Of course it passed
the first test.
One by one was okay.
But two by two was not,
was at the borderline.
What else should I think?
Oh, that's a very
interesting case.
The borderline.
You know, it almost makes it.
But can you tell me the
eigenvalues of that matrix?
Don't do any
quadratic equations.
How do I know, what's one
eigenvalue of a matrix?
You made it singular, right?
You made that matrix singular.
Determinant zero.
So one of its
eigenvalues is zero.
And the other one is visible
by looking at the trace.
I just quickly mentioned
that if I add the diagonal,
I get the same answer as if
I add the two eigenvalues.
So that other
eigenvalue must be ten.
And this is entirely
typical, that ten and zero,
the extreme eigenvalues,
lambda_max and lambda_min,
are bigger than-- these
diagonal guys are inside.
They're inside,
between zero and ten
and it's these terms that
enter somehow and gave us
an eigenvalue of ten and
an eigenvalue of zero.
I guess I'm tempted to
try to draw that figure.
Just to get a feeling
of what's with that one.
It always helps to get
the borderline case.
So what's with this one?
Let me see what my
quadratic would be.
Can I just change it up here?
Rather than rewriting it.
So I'm going to,
I'll put it up here.
So I have to change
that four to what?
Now that I'm looking
at this matrix.
That four is now a six.
Six.
This is my guy for this one.
Which is not positive definite.
Let me tell you
right away the word
that I would use for this one.
I would call it positive
semi-definite because it's
almost there, but not quite.
So semi-definite allows
the matrix to be singular.
So semi-definite,
maybe I'll do it
in green what
semi-definite would be.
Semi-def would be eigenvalues
greater than or equal zero.
Determinants greater
than or equal zero.
Pivots greater than zero
if they're there or then
we run out of pivots.
You could say greater than
or equal to zero then.
And energy, greater
than or equal to zero
for semi-definite.
And when would the energy, what
x's, what would be the like,
you could say the ground
states or something,
what x's-- So greater
than or equal to zero,
emphasize that possibility
of equal in the semi-definite
case.
Suppose I have a semi-definite
matrix, yeah, I've got one.
But it's singular.
So that means a singular matrix
takes some vector x to zero.
Right?
If my matrix is
actually singular,
then there'll be an
x where Kx is zero.
And then, of course,
multiplying by x transpose,
I'm still at zero.
So the x's, the zero energy
guys, this is straightforward,
the zero energy guys, the ones
where x transpose Kx is zero,
will happen when Kx is zero.
If Kx is zero, and we'll
see it in that example.
Let's see it in that example.
What's the x for
which, I could say
in the null space,
what's the vector x
that that matrix kills?
[3, -1], right?
The vector [3, -1].
[3, -1] gives me [0, 0].
That's the vector that-- So
I get 3-3, the zero, 9-9,
the zero.
So I believe that
this thing will
be-- Is it zero at [3, -1]?
I think that it
has to be, right?
If I take x_1 to be three
and x_2 to be minus one,
I think I've got
zero energy here.
Do I? x_1 squared will be
nine and nine x_2 squared
will be nine more.
And what will be this 6x_1*x_2?
What will that come out
for this x_1 and x_2?
Minus 18.
Had to, right?
So I'd get nine from there,
nine from there, minus 18, zero.
So the graph for this
positive semi-definite
will look a bit like this.
There'll be a direction
in which it doesn't climb.
It doesn't go below
the base, right?
It's never negative.
This is now the
semi-definite picture.
But it can run along the base.
And it will for the
vector x_1=3, x_2=-1,
I don't know where that
is, one, two, three,
and then maybe minus one.
Along some line here
the graph doesn't go up.
It's sitting, can you imagine
that sitting in the base?
I'm not Rembrandt here, but in
the other direction it goes up.
Oh, the hell with that one.
Do you see, sort of?
It's like a trough,
would you say?
I mean, it's like
a, you know, a bit
of a drainpipe or something.
It's running along the ground,
along this [3, -1] direction
and in the other
directions it does go up.
So it's shaped like this
with the base not climbing.
Whereas here, there's
no bad direction.
Climbs every way you go.
So that's positive definite and
that's positive semi-definite.
Well suppose I push
it a little further.
Let me make a place here
for a matrix that isn't
even positive semi-definite.
Now it's just going
to go down somewhere.
I'll start again
with one and nine
and tell me what to put in now.
So this is going to be a case
where the off-diagonal is
too big, it wins.
And prevents positive definite.
So what number
would you like here?
Five?
Five is certainly plenty.
So now I have [1, 5; 5, 9].
Let me take a little space
on a board just to show you.
Sorry about that.
So I'm going to do
the [1, 5; 5,  9]
just because they're
all important,
but then we're coming
back to positive definite.
So if it's [1, 5; 5, 9] and
I do that usual x transpose
Kx and I do the multiplication
out, I see the one x_1 squared
and I see the nine x_2 squareds.
And how many x_1*x_2's do I see?
Five from there,
five from there, ten.
And I believe that
can be negative.
The fact of having
all nice plus signs
is not going to help it
because we can choose,
as we already did, x_1 to be
like a negative number and x_2
to be a positive.
And we can get this guy to
be negative and make it,
in this case we can make it
defeat these positive parts.
What choice would do it?
Let me take x_1 to be
minus one and tell me
an x_2 that's good enough to
show that this thing is not
positive definite or
even semi-definite,
it goes downhill.
Take x_2 equal?
What do you say?
1/2?
Yeah, I don't want
too big an x_2
because if I have too big an
x_2, then this'll be important.
Does 1/2 do it?
So I've got 1/4, that's
positive, but not very.
9/4, so I'm up to 10/4,
but this guy is what?
Ten and the minus is minus five.
Yeah.
So that absolutely goes, at this
one I come out less than zero.
And I might as well complete.
So this is the case where
I would call it indefinite.
Indefinite.
It goes up, like if
x_2 is zero, then
it's just got x_1
squared, that's up.
If x_1 is zero, it's only
got x_2 squared, that's up.
But there are other directions
where it goes downhill.
So it goes either up-- it
goes both up in some ways
and down in others.
And what kind of a graph,
what kind of a surface
would I now have for x
transpose for this x transpose,
this indefinite guy?
So up in some ways
and down in others.
This gets really hard to draw.
I believe that if
you ride horses
you have an edge on
visualizing this.
So it's called, what kind
of a point's it called?
Saddle point, it's
called a saddle point.
So what's a saddle point?
That's not bad, right?
So this is a direction
where it went up.
This is a direction
where it went down.
And so it sort of
fills in somehow.
Or maybe, if you don't, I
mean, who rides horses now?
Actually maybe something we
do do is drive over mountains.
So the path, if the road
is sort of well-chosen,
the road will go,
it'll look for the,
this would be-- Yeah,
here's our road.
We would do as little
climbing as possible.
The mountain would go
like this, sort of.
So this would be
like, the bottom part
looking along the
peaks of the mountains.
But it's the top part looking
along the driving direction.
So driving, it's a maximum, but
in the mountain range direction
it's a minimum.
So it's a saddle point.
So that's what you get from
a typical symmetric matrix.
And if it was minus five it
would still be the same saddle
point, would still be
9-25, it would still
be negative and a saddle.
Positive guys are our thing.
Alright.
So now back to
positive definite.
With these four tests
and then the discussion
of semi-definite.
Very key, that energy.
Let me just look ahead a moment.
Most physical problems,
many, many physical problems,
you have an option.
Either you solve some equations,
either you find the solution
from our equations,
Ku=f, typically.
Matrix equation or
differential equation.
Or there's another option
of minimizing some function.
Some energy.
And it gives the same equations.
So this minimizing energy
will be a second way
to describe the applications.
Now can I get a number five?
There's an important
number five and then
you know really all you need to
know about symmetric matrices.
This gives me, about
positive definite matrices,
this gives me a chance to recap.
So I'm going to put
down a number five.
Because this is where
the matrices come from.
Really important.
And it's where they'll come
from in all these applications
that chapter two is going
to be all about, that we're
going to start.
So they come, these
positive definite matrices,
so this is another
way to, it's a test
for positive definite matrices
and it's, actually, it's
where they come from.
So here's a positive
definite matrix.
They come from A transpose
A. A fundamental message is
that if I have just
an average matrix,
possibly rectangular, could
be a square but not symmetric,
then sooner or later,
in fact usually sooner,
you end up looking
at A transpose A.
We've seen that already.
And we already know that
A transpose A is square,
we already know it's
symmetric and now
we're going to know that
it's positive definite.
So matrices like A transpose
A are positive definite
or possibly semi-definite.
There's that possibility.
If A was the zero
matrix, of course,
we would just get
the zero matrix which
would be only
semi-definite, or other ways
to get a semi-definite.
So I'm saying that if K, if
I have a matrix, any matrix,
and I form A transpose A, I
get a positive definite matrix
or maybe just semi-definite,
but not indefinite.
Can we see why?
Why is this positive
definite or semi-?
So that's my question.
And the answer is
really worth-- it's
just neat and worth seeing.
So do I want to look at the
pivots of A transpose A?
No.
They're something,
but whatever they are,
I can't really
follow those well.
Or the eigenvalues very
well, or the determinants.
None of those come out nicely.
But the real guy
works perfectly.
So look at x transpose Kx.
So I'm just doing--
following my instinct here.
So if K is A
transpose A, my claim
is, what am I saying
then about this energy?
What is it that I want to
discover and understand?
Why it's positive.
Why does taking any
matrix, multiplying
by its transpose produce
something that's positive?
Can you see any reason
why that quantity,
which looks kind
of messy, I just
want to look at it
the right way to see
why that should be positive,
that should come out positive.
So I'm not going to
get into numbers,
I'm not going to get into
diagonals and off-diagonals.
I'm just going to do
one thing to understand
that particular combination,
x transpose A transpose Ax.
What shall I do?
Anybody see what I might do?
Yeah, you're seeing here
if you look at it again,
what are you seeing here?
Tell me again.
If I take Ax together,
then what's the other half?
It's the transpose of Ax.
So I just want to write
that as, I just want
to think of it that way, as Ax.
And here's the transpose of Ax.
Right?
Because transposes
of Ax, so transpose
guys in the opposite order,
and the multiplication--
This is the great.
I call these proof
by parenthesis
because I'm just putting
parentheses in the right place,
but the key law of
matrix multiplication
is that, that I can put
(AB)C is the same as A(BC).
That rule, which is
just multiply it out
and you see that
parentheses are not
needed because if you keep
them in the right order
you can do this first,
or you can do this first.
Same answer.
What do I learn from that?
What was the point?
This is some vector, I don't
know especially what it is,
times its transpose.
So that's the length squared.
What's the key fact about that?
That it is never negative.
It's always greater than
zero or possibly equal.
When does that
quantity equal zero?
When Ax is zero.
Because this is a vector.
That's the same
vector transposed.
And everybody's
got that picture.
When I take any y
transpose y, I get
y_1 squared plus y_2
squared through y_n squared.
And I get a positive answer
except if the vector is zero.
So it's zero when Ax is zero.
So that's going to be the key.
If I pick any matrix
A, and I can just
take an example, but
chapter-- the applications
are just going to
be full of examples.
Where the problem begins
with a matrix A and then
A transpose shows up and it's
the combination A transpose A
that we work with.
And we're just learning
that it's positive definite.
Unless, shall I just hang
on since I've got here,
I have to say when is it, have
to get these two possibilities.
Positive definite or
only semi-definite.
So what's the key to
that borderline question?
This thing will be
only semi-definite
if there's a solution to Ax=0.
If there is an x, well,
there's always the zero vector.
Zero vector I can't
expect to be positive.
So I'm looking for
if there's an x so
that Ax is zero
but x is not zero,
then I'll only be semi-definite.
That's the test.
If there is a solution to Ax=0.
When we see applications
that'll mean
there's a displacement
with no stretching.
We might have a line
of springs and when
could the line of springs
displace with no stretching?
When it's free-free, right?
If I have a line of springs
and no supports at the ends,
then that would be the case
where it could shift over
by the [1, 1, 1] vector.
So that would be the case where
the matrix is only singular.
We know that.
The matrix is now
positive semi-definite.
We just learned that.
So the free-free
matrix, like B, both
ends free, or C.
So our answer is
going to be that K and
T are positive definite.
And our other two guys, the
singular ones, of course,
just don't make it.
B at both ends, the
free-free line of springs,
it can shift without stretching.
Since Ax will measure the
stretching when it just
shifts rigid motion,
the Ax is zero
and we see only
positive definite.
And also C, the circular one.
There it can displace
with no stretching
because it can just
turn in the circle.
So these guys will be only
positive semi-definite.
Maybe I better say
this another way.
When is this positive definite?
Can I use just a
different sentence
to describe this possibility?
This is positive
definite provided,
so what I'm going to write now
is to remove this possibility
and get positive definite.
This is positive
definite provided, now,
I could say it this way.
The A has independent columns.
So I just needed to give you
another way of looking at this
Ax=0 question.
If A has independent
columns, what does that mean?
That means that the only
solution to Ax=0 is the zero
solution.
In other words, it means that
this thing works perfectly
and gives me positive.
When A has independent columns.
Let's just remember our K,
T, B, C. So here's a matrix,
so let me take the T matrix,
that's this one, this guy.
And then the third
column is [0,  -1, 2].
Those three columns
are independent.
They point off.
They don't lie in a plane.
They point off in three
different directions.
And then there are no solutions
to, no x's that go Kx=0.
So that would be a case
of independent columns.
Let me make a case
of dependent columns.
So, and I'm going
to make it B now.
Now the columns of that
matrix are dependent.
There's a combination
of them that give zero.
They all lie in the same plane.
There's a solution to that
matrix times x equal zero.
What combination
of those columns
shows me that they
are dependent?
That some combination
of those three columns,
some amount of this
plus some amount
of this plus some
amount of that column
gives me the zero vector.
You see the combination.
What should I take?
[1, 1, 1] again.
No surprise.
That's the vector
[1, 1, 1] that we
know is in the-- everything
shifting the same amount,
nothing stretching.
Talking fast here about
positive definite matrices.
This is the key.
Let's just ask a few questions
about positive definite
matrices as a way to practice.
Suppose I had one.
Positive definite.
What about its inverse?
Is that positive
definite or not?
So I've got a positive definite
one, it's not singular,
it's got positive
eigenvalues, everything else.
It's inverse will
be symmetric, so I'm
allowed to think about it.
Will it be positive definite?
What do you think?
Well, you've got a
whole bunch of tests
to sort of mentally run through.
Pivots of the inverse, you
don't want to touch that stuff.
Determinants, no.
What about eigenvalues?
What would be the
eigenvalues if I
have this positive
definite symmetric matrix,
its eigenvalues are
one, four, five.
What can you tell me
about the eigenvalues
of the inverse matrix?
They're the inverses.
So those three eigenvalues are?
1, 1/4, 1/5, what's
the conclusion here?
It is positive definite.
Those are all positive,
it is positive definite.
So if I invert a
positive definite matrix,
I'm still positive definite.
All the tests
would have to pass.
It's just I'm looking each
time for the easiest test.
Let me look now, for the
easiest test on K_1+K_2.
Suppose that's positive definite
and that's positive definite.
What if I add them?
What do you think?
Well, we hope so.
But we have to say which of
my one, two, three, four, five
would be a good way to see it.
Would be a good way to see it.
Good question.
Four?
We certainly don't
want to touch pivots
and now we don't want to
touch eigenvalues either.
Of course, if number four
works, others will also work.
The eigenvalues will
come out positive.
But not too easy to
say what they are.
Let's try test number four.
So K_1.
What's the test?
So test number four
tells us that this part,
x transpose K_1*x, that that
part is positive, right?
That that part is positive.
If we know that's
positive definite.
Now, about K_2 we also know
that for every x, you see it's
for every x, that helps.
Don't let me put x_2 there.
For every x, this
will be positive.
And now what's the
step I want to take?
To get some information
on the matrix K_1+K_2.
I should add.
If I add these guys, you
see that it just, then I
can write that as, I
can write that this way.
And what have I learned?
I've learned that that's
positive, even greater than,
except for the zero vector.
Because this was greater
than, this is greater than.
If I add two positive numbers,
the energies are positive
and the energies just add.
The energies just add.
So that definition four was the
good way, just nice, easy way
to see that if I have a couple
of positive definite matrices,
a couple of positive
energies, I'm really
coupling the two systems.
This is associated somehow.
I've got two systems,
I'm putting them together
and the energy is just
even more positive.
It's more positive either of
these guys because I'm adding.
As I'm speaking
here, will you allow
me to try test number five,
this A transpose A business?
Suppose K_1 was A transpose
A. If it's positive definite,
it will.
Be And suppose K_2
is B transpose B.
If it's positive
definite, it will be.
Now I would like to
write the sum somehow as,
in this something
transpose something.
And I just do it
now because I think
it's like, you won't perhaps
have thought of this way
to do it.
Watch.
Suppose I create
the matrix [A;  B].
That'll be my new matrix.
Say, call it C. Am I
allowed to do that?
I mean, that creates a matrix?
These A and B, they had the
same number of columns, n.
So I can put one over
the other and I still
have something with n columns.
So that's my new matrix C.
And now I want C transpose.
By the way, I'd call
that a block matrix.
You know, instead of numbers,
it's got two blocks in there.
Block matrices are really handy.
Now what's the transpose
of that block matrix?
You just have faith, just
have faith with blocks.
It's just like numbers.
If I had a matrix [1; 5]
then I'd get a row one, five.
But what do you think?
This is worth thinking
about even after class.
What would be, if this C
matrix is this block A above B,
what do you think
for C transpose?
A transpose, B
transpose side by side.
Just put in numbers
and you'd see it.
And now I'm going
to take C transpose
times C. I'm calling
it C now instead of A
because I've used the
A in the first guy
and I've used B in the second
one and now I'm ready for C.
How do you multiply
block matrices?
Again, you just have faith.
What do you think?
Tell me the answer.
A transpose, I
multiply that by that
just as if they were numbers.
And I add that times that
And what do I have?
I've got K_1+K_2.
So I've written K_1, this is
K_1+K_2 and this is in my form
C transpose C that I was looking
for, that number five was
looking for.
So it's done it.
It's done it.
The fact of getting A-- K_1 in
this form, K_2 in this form.
And I just made a block
matrix and I got K_1+K_2.
That's not a big deal in
itself, but block matrices
are really handy.
It's good to take that
step with matrices.
Think of, possibly, the
entries as coming in blocks
and not just one at a time.
Well, thank you, okay.
I swear Friday we'll
start applications
in all kinds of
engineering problems
and you'll have
new applications.